giant squid are a main character in
books and movies about the deep ocean
whether it's 20 000 Leagues Under the
Sea or Pirates of the Caribbean but the
possibility of actually running into one
of these 60 foot long behemoths is
pretty low right well maybe not looking
into the stomachs of sperm whales who
hunt giant squid scientists have come up
with some pretty alarming numbers if all
the sperm whales in the world only ate
one giant squid per week they'd consume
more than 18.7 million squid every year
but based on the giant squid beaks found
inside sperm whale stomachs scientists
think they might eat one every day
that makes a yearly total of over 131
million giant squid the deep ocean is in
fact absolutely full of these elusive
Giants
foreign